today on the matte wall show now they're
coming for abraham lincoln after thomas
jefferson's name was taken off of a
school in virginia last week now abraham
lincoln high school in california
is getting a name change the purge of
our history continues and it began
with the attack on confederate statues
lots of people who went along with that
are now appalled by the results of
really their own actions
we'll talk about that today also five
headlines including news from a doctor
on msnbc that
even if you get a vaccine you still
can't travel or live your normal life
and a famous evangelist claims that
trumpism is the greatest threat facing
the church
today trumpism is plus your daily
cancellation and much more today on the
matt walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
well as we get to the end of the year
you know i'm i'm surveying
uh the list of uh my my reading goal for
the year i had a certain
number of books i wanted to read and i'm
looking at that list and realizing that
i didn't come anywhere close to it i
have an excuse i've moved you know it's
been a busy year and all that
but the fact is we're all busy and we
don't have time to read all the books we
want to read
and you know the problem is you're not
gaining the knowledge you want to gain
that's why it's so great that a website
like thinker.org exists
thinker is great because in our
fast-paced world it's tough to make
reading a priority
and that's why at thinker.org they
summarize the key ideas from new and
noteworthy nonfiction
giving you access to an entire library
of great books in bite size form
and what they're going to do is they're
going to you know they're going to take
all the insights all the wisdom in that
book all the information
they're going to give it to you and so
you're able to ingest that and learn
and grow as a person and be exposed to
these new ideas even if you don't have
time to read the entire book
thinker offers a large variety of titles
across many categories from
current affairs politics business
education
history relationships and you'll find
titles like my own book the unholy
trinity is there ben shapiro's right
side of history
but it doesn't stop there they've got
tons of titles and you got to go check
it out
if you want to challenge your
preconceptions expand your horizons gain
knowledge become a better thinker
go to thinkor.org that's
t-h-i-n-k-r-dot-org to start a free
trial and download the app today
let them know you heard about them on
the matt wall show that's thinker.org
all right uh and as you can see if
you're watching i have my uh
my leftist tears tumbler here with my
sloth
tea infuser i'm told that's what it is
uh you can go to instagram and see the
videos they're
they're giving me gifts i guess they
keep giving me gifts until they find one
that i like but
i feel like you're not trying that hard
if a sloth tea infuser
is your idea of something that that i
would like uh although it is you know
it's it's i could get used to it i kind
of like having it here
as my buddy on the desk now it's been
frustrating enough you know to watch
people on the right for so many years
go along with the left's cultural agenda
seeding ground
making compromise after compromise
compromises that always seem to involve
the left getting what it wants and us
getting nothing that's usually what the
compromise is
that's not a compromise at all by the
way that's surrender but what makes the
spectacle unbearable really is when
those same people on the right act
surprised
shocked appalled by the results of their
own cowardice
we've been seeing quite a bit of this
sort of thing in recent days
first with the announcement that a
school district in virginia would be
taking thomas jefferson's name off of
their elementary school
because he owned slaves and now with the
news latest news that san francisco will
be renaming
renaming its abraham lincoln high school
though abraham lincoln
quite famously did not own slaves he did
not own slaves
but he did commit other moral crimes
that now prohibit him from having a
school named after him
the daily mail has the report it says
quote the district's renaming committee
decided lincoln is not worthy of keeping
his name in abraham lincoln high school
because quote the majority of his
policies prove to be detrimental to
native americans
abraham lincoln is not seen as much of a
hero at all among the
american indian nations and native
peoples of the united states as the
majority of his policies prove to be
detrimental to them
the committee the the committee uh
meeting notes state
under his watch indigenous peoples had
much of their land taken away from them
in 1862 the homestead act
where citizens could claim ownership
ownership of 160 acres of land
and the pacific railway act which gave
railroad companies permission to build a
transcontinental railroad across the
america
led to the significant loss of land and
natural resources as well as the loss of
lifestyle and culture for many
indigenous peoples
jeremiah jeremiah jeffries chairman of
the renaming committee and a first grade
teacher
told the san francisco chronicle quote
lincoln
like the presidents before him and most
after did not show through policy or
rhetoric
that black lives ever mattered to them
outside of human capital and as
casualties of wealth building
so they can't get lincoln on the slavery
issue instead they get them on native
americans
and it's true that native americans had
a rough time of it under lincoln it's
true that once europeans arrived in the
new world 500 years ago
a process began which would eventually
lead to most native americans being
driven from their land
a great many would die though the
majority of those would die through
disease
unknowingly brought here by the settlers
all of that is true it's also true
that the european and then american
conquest of the new world occurred at a
time in history
when all lines were drawn and nations
established in areas settled and claimed
through conquest this was the rule
across the globe
everywhere among everyone for thousands
of years
with no exceptions if you wanted land
you had to take it
if you wanted to keep what you already
took you had to defend it
if you couldn't defend it you would lose
it that was the way of the world for
most of human history
and it was especially the way among
native americans themselves who were in
a constant state of war with with with
each other other tribes fighting and
killing and enslaving each other
stealing land
then having it stolen from them then the
europeans showed up and played the same
game of conquest and won now somehow
after thousands of years of fighting and
bloodshed across the globe
the descendants of those europeans who
also happened to establish
the greatest civilization the world's
ever seen are supposed to be the only
ones
racked with guilt constantly apologizing
and tearing down our monuments and
reparation
it's ridiculous but not according to
jeremiah jeffries chairman of the
renaming committee
he's decided that lincoln didn't do
enough for black lives
as he put it of course lincoln did more
than jeremiah jeffries
has done or could do in a thousand
lifetimes
lincoln was a man of consequence a
history maker
world shaper jeremiah jeffries in
contrast
is mediocre vacuous and we live in a
time when lots of mediocre vacuous
people are deciding
that the great men of history don't live
up to their own standards
they're like morbidly obese gluttons
laying on the couch
eating cheetos watching a bodybuilding
competition and complaining that the
competitors
are a little too flabby but and here's
the point
this is not happening out of nowhere or
in a vacuum we can draw a direct
clear line from the tearing down of
confederate monuments and the renaming
of street schools and military
installations
to this attack on abraham lincoln or
jefferson or washington
in fact some of us said years ago when
this began
myself included that it would lead to
this very point
that the exact logic used to
posthumously condemn robert e lee could
just as well be applied to lincoln
or to anyone else in history and we were
told even by conservatives
that such a slippery slope argument is a
fallacy
and there's no reason why the historical
purge has to go beyond confederates
no it'll stop right here we were told
well it didn't we were right and we're
right about this too it's not over
it doesn't end here it will never end
not until every single hero of american
history of western history
has been tried from the grave and
condemned as a racist and a villain
none are safe certainly none of the
white males though i would predict that
eventually
you know they're going to get around to
men like martin luther king jr
for his behavior with women uh
eventually they get around to everyone
because all people who existed prior to
about 10 years ago
were problematic and had problematic
views
according to the standards of the modern
left meanwhile
in mongolia they have statues to genghis
khan
and honor him as a hero he caused the
deaths of 40 million people
40 million in the 13th century
and he wasn't using guns and bombs
there are 16 million men alive today
related to genghis khan
largely because he was such a prolific
rapist
so a mass murderer and a serial rapist
and yet nobody in mongolia thinks of
tearing down a statue
nor are they terribly torn up and
guilt-ridden by the actions of their
hero 700 years ago
now you could argue that they take it
too far in the other direction genghis
khan was after all
one of the most evil men of history
comparable to hitler and pol pot and
people in that tier but
i think mongolians are more correct in
their approach
to their historical heroes than we are
right now in our approach to ours
it is better to honor problematic
historical figures than to honor
no historical figures at least there's a
humility
in recognizing the achievements of your
ancestors at least there's a gratitude
in appreciating what they did to form
the civilization in which you live
i would take that over having no
gratitude no appreciation
no acknowledgement look it's long past
time
to choose a side on this
you're either with the woke mob tearing
down our history or you're against them
you can't be with them on some things
and against them on others
you can't say well i'll pick up the
pitchfork and call for this statue to be
torn down but then that's going to be
it no the woke mob must be opposed on
principle
in everything even if you would
otherwise agree with them about
something even if there's a statue
you also don't like and they're saying
tear it down
you should say well i don't like the
statue either but since you maniacs are
trying to pull it down i say keep it and
build another
bigger one and put it right next to that
one
that is the only way to deal with these
people there is no other way
to give them nothing nothing give them
nothing that's the only way
and now the very latest development
andrew cuomo
this is breaking news today will be
signing a bill to outlaw the sale of
confederate flags
to outlaw the sale of cover flags in new
york which is outrageously
unconstitutional of course i mean it
doesn't even come close
to approaching the realm of
constitutional it's also
pointless as new york is not exactly
known as a bastion of confederate
sympathizers
but if any mention of the confederacy is
so traumatizing to the sensitive souls
walking around today that we have to
take down the statues and remove the
names
then sure why not ban the flags too to
wave the flag itself is a is a
is a hate crime an act of violence
that's the logic
it's bad logic it's indefensible it's
appalling it's stupid
but it's where we are and we have the
cowardice and short-sightedness of many
conservatives
to thank for it now let's get to our
five headlines
[Music]
before we get to our five headlines
today you know a problem for a lot of
guys
is that we can tend to be reluctant to
go to the doctor we don't feel like
going we're embarrassed to go
and that's why it's so great that one of
our new sponsors for hims.com
exists and is there for us for hims.com
is all about men's wellness
if you need help with ed hair loss if
you have a cold really anything if
you're interested in mental health or
cova 19 home test
whatever it is hymns is here for you
through hymns you can get prescription
medication that treats
many things but ed you know this is real
science real solutions to ed hims makes
it easy hims connects you to
a licensed medical professional online
and can prescribe
fda approved prescription medication to
treat ed get the same active ingredient
as the expensive little pill but without
the expensive price tag
and if approved your medication is
shipped directly to your door to
discreet packaging
and shipping is also free so that's it's
it's easy
you know it's discreet and uh it's an
easy thing to fit into your life
why live with ed when the solution can
be so simple
um and if you have you know if you have
a problem there's a solution out there
for it then there's just no reason
to live with the problem if you don't
have to so try hymns today by starting
out with a free online visit go to for
hymns.com
matt for your free visit that's for
dot hymns.coms.com slash matt
prescription products are subject to
medical provider approval and require an
online consultation with a medical
provider who will determine if a
prescription is appropriate
see website for full details and safety
information remember that's for hims.com
matt uh by the way ben shapiro on his
show today is gonna be
he's gonna have more about this uh
lincoln situation also i'll be joining
uh to to talk about it as well
so you could tune in for that um and i
just saw this now this is not one of our
headlines but i'm just sort of tacking
it on to the to the front here
um but i want you to look at this
headline from the website queerty
uh it says let's see
it says pete budage makes history as
first
out cabinet member he was nominated as a
transportation
secretary for unclear reasons i'm not
sure that he has any i don't know what
expertise he has in the realm of
transportation but uh they were you know
they they wanted to give him a cabinet
kind of a you know it's a runner-up sort
of prize that they give and so they said
oh we'll make him transportation
secretary
so that's that's the headline right pete
budage makes history his first
uh gay out cabinet member then here's
another headline though
also from queerty and this is from not
even a year ago this is from february of
2020.
it says trump makes richard grinnell
first openly gay cabinet secretary in
history
again this is the same publication
within a year
first claiming that richard grenell is
the is the first gay
cabinet uh official and now they're
saying i don't know actually it's
it's buddhija he's the first gay one
how do you make sense of that it's it's
we talk about erasing history
okay they don't need to go back 150
years to a race history they're going to
erase history that happened
like 10 months ago and just pretend that
that yeah
we're going to pretend it didn't happen
yeah pete budage is the first second
gay cabinet official he's the first one
to be the second one
and i would even say and you know this
is credit to him he's probably gonna be
the only second one
there will never be another second gay
cabinet official
so give him credit for that or you could
even say i mean
he is the probably right the first
openly gay
cabinet official in the department of
transportation
which is probably the most boring
political milestone in history
which is itself another milestone so why
don't we just go with that
that that should be the headline pete
budage lays claim to most boring
uh political milestone in history that's
an accomplishment
all right number one vaccines are now
being administered with trump having
made good on his promise to
have a vaccine available by the end of
the year many in the media mocked trump
for saying that and have of course not
apologized or admitted that they were
wrong instead
they've moved on to explaining why well
okay yeah he did get the vaccine to us
but
actually the vaccine's basically
pointless because even after you take it
you still can't resume your normal life
here's a doctor and pandemic consultant
quote unquote
on msnbc explaining watch uh tomorrow
morning and
i'm grateful for it um chuck i just
wanted to say uh
just a follow up on what yes mean
mentioned i
just for your viewers out there um i
know one of uh the
individuals who we just saw getting
backstage is planning on traveling after
the second dose
i i this is a source of confusion but no
this is one of the misperceptions here
just because you get vaccinated with
that second dose
does not mean you should be
participating in things like
traveling in the middle of an out of
control pandemic or that you're
liberated from masks
everything still applies until all of us
get the two dose regimen we don't think
that's going to happen until june july
but and again this goes back to what we
just talked about chuck
we don't know if just getting the
vaccination prevents
serious illness or does it also prevent
you from getting infection
entirely meaning you can still get
infected with the virus potentially and
pass it on to others
so really really critical don't let your
guard down just because you got
vaccinated
you still might be able to connect with
a virus and pass on others so please
keep that in mind
okay so the so according to him the vi
the vaccine is meaningless pointless
doesn't do anything according to him
that's
that's that appears to be what he's
saying
well yeah it's a source of confusion oh
oh you were confused you thought the
vaccine did something no no no
no you still everything goes on exactly
how it how it has been even after you
get the vaccine
until we all get it well why is that is
this like what i tell my kids where
you know nobody's allowed to leave the
table until everybody's finished eating
that to me is just a matter of courtesy
and and good etiquette so is that
is that what we're doing here well it
wouldn't be courteous it'd be bad
etiquette
if you get a vaccine and then you start
running around without a mask and you
get to go on a vacation makes everyone
feel bad and so you shouldn't do that
until everyone else could do it too
is that what they're telling us i would
prefer that logic
over what it appears that he's saying
which is that yeah even if after you get
the vaccine there's still a chance you
could get it
there's a chance all right well
if if that's the logic then the
lockdowns
never end and masking never ends
because there's always going to be a
chance even after everybody gets the vet
even if every man woman and child in
america gets a vaccine
still there's going to be a chance right
there's always a chance
there's a chance you could get any
disease that you get vaccinated for
there's always a chance
the flu there's a chance you get a
really bad case of
flu even even after you get the flu shot
so if that's all it is if it's just well
there's still a chance
as long as there's a chance it means you
can't resume your normal life okay well
that means we will never resume our
normal lives
uh number two staying on covid for
another moment here a video went viral
yesterday of a man
in extremely short shorts chasing and
berating a woman
in a store uh because she wasn't wearing
a mask we've seen this kind of thing
before but this is
more aggressive um this is a man who is
more aggressive and certainly is
showing more of his leg than we've seen
before and would like to see
but uh here it is watch put your
mask on i'm sorry you can walk away from
me right now sir
put your mask on get away from me put it
on does it bother anybody else that she
doesn't have to
wear a mask that we all do just go away
stay six feet away from me then no
get away from me no yeah please get away
from me right now
no you don't know why you don't need to
come near me she has it on her damn hand
get away from me
walk away from me sir please get away
from me
i know who you voted for i know who you
voted for
um i i hadn't seen the end of that video
i like that
i think we all i think we all know who
that guy voted for and
the first thing that comes to mind for
me again is just i i know this isn't
really the headline but does he not have
anyone in his life
that that loves him and cares about him
and saw him leaving the house in those
shorts and said hey
whoa let's no no no no no no no the
whole get up the
the shirt if you're just listening to
this by the way if you're listening to
this
and you didn't see the video um
you have an image in your head of what
that guy probably looks like
that's exactly it the image you have in
your head that you've drawn in your head
of that man
you're right that is exact it's exactly
what you think
and really that's just no man at all i
call him a man only loosely
only in a strictly biological sense
assuming you know if i could
his biology but in every other sense
that is no man at all
speaking to a woman that way first of
all wearing those shorts in that shirt
and just being a coward this is what i
would talk about all the time now
this normalization of of cowardice
someone's so afraid oh you're gonna get
me sick put a mask on you're gonna get
me sick
i'm scared i'm scared of my short shorts
you should be the one covering up i'd
much rather be in a in a
building with a hundred people without
masks on than a hundred
guys like that wearing those shorts
uh there's another so and there's
there's a comparison being drawn here
i'm not sure if the comparison is fair
but there's another video uh really
audio that's that's gone viral yesterday
this one of uh tom cruise and on the set
of the latest
mission impossible i think they're on
mission impossible 52 now
and he's berating some of the people
some of the workers on set
for uh not following the coveted
guidelines
and he makes his opinion known loud and
clear here it is listen
hollywood making movies right now
because of us
because they believe in us and what
we're doing
i'm on the phone with every studio at
night
insurance companies producers
and they're looking at us and using us
to make their movies
we are creating thousands of jobs
i don't ever want to see it again ever
and if you don't do it you're fired and
i see you do it again you're
gone and anyone on this crew does it
that's it and you too and you too
and you if you ever do it again
that's it no apologies
you can tell it to the people that are
losing their own
because our industry is shut down it's
not going to put food on their table
or pay for their college education
that's what i sleep with every night
yeah i'm not really i'm not sure
i think i didn't get a pulse on on how
people are reacting to that
i actually i don't hate it
i don't really care one way or another
to be honest about tom cruise yelling
i thought i'd play it anyway but if i
had if i had to make a judgment call i
don't i don't
hate that i don't hate it nearly as much
as i hate the guy in the uh
in the store because tom cruise you know
he's
basically these are his employees he's a
producer of the film
and they have strict guidelines they
have to follow otherwise the movie gets
shut down a lot of people lose their
jobs
and so he needs people just do it and
and play the game so we can keep you
know so we can keep to keep it going
um so that to me is different from
just some random dude and short shorts
at the at the grocery store
chasing a woman down for not wearing i
mean he's got no authority
i say the same thing about you know if
i'm if i'm out in public
and someone and this has happened to me
i mentioned before someone comes up to
me says why don't you wear a mask just
some random shmo walking down the street
i'm not gonna pay any attention to them
now if i walk into a store and an
employee or manager there says we need
you to wear the mask
i don't like it i'll respect that
because you have the authority to tell
me that
in your establishment i can always leave
um
so i i i'm gonna say i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna say tom cruise is not canceled
over that one the guy in the short
shorts is
all right let's go to number three
lengthy new york times article
published yesterday getting a lot of
reaction
and i'll be honest with you i didn't
even read it um
as i feel like i didn't need to but the
headline is
how the journalist jeffrey toobin went
from respected new yorker writer
to hashtag punchline and subject of
debate
the reason i read it is because i think
i know
um masturbating in front of his
co-workers that's how it happened
that's a you know that is a one-way
ticket to being a punchline and a
hashtag
and really there's no what is there to
debate that's what he did
it is interesting though to see though
not surprising in the media this
attempted rehabilitation
of jeffrey toobin considering all the
people that these
folks in the media have tried to destroy
you know going back even to nick sandman
a kid
in a hat standing outside smiling at a
native american drumming in his face
but we're going to try to destroy him
but jeffrey toobin let's try to
rehabilitate him
let's just remember that with with
jeffrey toobin
it's not as though he was in the privacy
of his own home
and just on his own and then someone
like
hacked into his webcam and got a video
of this and then posted it or something
if that happened then i would say he's a
victim here
that's not what happened he was on he
was in his a meeting
he was in a meeting with his co-workers
and decided to drop his pants and get to
work
it's entirely different you do something
like that yeah you deserve to be fired
and of course you're going to be a punch
line how else are we supposed to respond
to that
it still has not become entirely clear
to me because
i i are the people defending jeffrey
toobin i don't think any of them have
defended
louis c.k they these
guys to me did basically the same thing
so i'm not sure i see the difference
other than louis c.k
i guess got consent before he did it so
arguably he's not as bad as jeffrey tube
all right let's go to uh number four
here i regret to inform you
they are dancing again they're back at
it the nurses
are dancing again on tock here's the
latest video this is from
yesterday i think it's a hospital in new
york the oh no it's boston it says right
there okay hospital in boston
boston medical center and uh they're
doing a little choreographed
dance routine let's uh let's watch that
[Music]
okay we can see that they've got okay
now this is the real choreographed move
here look at this guy in the blue suit
very blue suit he's really into it guys
in the background not so much
the reason why they're dancing
is that they're celebrating the vaccine
and so they're outside dancing this
really does remind me of
what i've read about um like with the
black plague in europe
and you know if you if you read you go
on wikipedia
uh doctors used to gather in the town
square and do synchronized dance
routines
and there's actually a really famous
photograph from the spanish flu pandemic
in 1918
of a doctor actually break dancing in
the middle of a hospital ward
another guy's doing the macarena he was
ahead of his time
oh wait no that none of that ever
happened because usually during
pandemics especially for being told the
doc the hospitals are overflowing and
the staff is overworked and everything
uh they're not gonna take time to
choreograph
that's what gets me it's the
choreographic the whole thing gets me
but if this was just a spontaneous spur
of the moment dancing
that would also be concerning but they
had to take some time
to choreograph that and to practice the
dance moves
all right number five i've been wanting
to mention this for a few days beth
moore
well-known christian evangelist um had
this to say a few days ago this was on
twitter
it got a lot of reaction she says i
don't believe
these are days for mincing words i'm 63
and a half years old and i've never seen
anything in these united states of
america i found more astonishingly
seductive and dangerous
to the saints of god than trumpism this
christian nationalism is not
of god move back from it fellow leaders
we will be held responsible for
remaining passive in this day of
seduction to save our own skin
while the saints we've been entrusted to
serve are being seduced manipulated
used and stirred up into a lather of
zeal devoid of the holy spirit for
political gain
and god help us we don't turn from
trumpism to bidenism
we do not worship flesh and blood we do
not place our faith in mortals we are
the church of the living god we can't
sanctify idolatry by labeling a leader
our cyrus we need no cyrus we have a
king his name is jesus
um now as far as i know first of all
this broadside against trumpism from
beth moore
this is the i think the first time she's
come out as
explicitly and directly as this
when trump is on his way out now she's
now she's showing up to say ah this
trumpism is a real problem
that first of all if you really feel
that way why don't you say four years
ago
i mean why haven't you been saying it
this whole time
uh so not exactly a
an example of courage there but also
even aside from that and i i could be
wrong by the way
maybe i haven't followed her work that
closely maybe she's been saying this
before if she has then
i'll retract that part of it but
regardless
um the idea that trumpism that people
being
too enthused about trump is the most
seductive and dangerous thing in the in
the church today in america
are you kidding me have you not been
paying attention to
what do you think was happening before
trump came along it was all fine and
dandy
the the church christianity in america
has been
in a state of collapse spread out over
decades
and trump had nothing to do with that
now i agree that
uh idol worshipping of a politician is a
problem
it's a problem on the left it's a
problem on the right
and i've always said that but it is by
no means even close anywhere near
the most dangerous or the greatest
threat the church faces today
la you want to talk about what's
seductive leftism
that's what's seductive just look at the
polls look at the surveys
look at the surveys of all the
christians who uh
who think that you know you could be a
christian and still be in favor of
babies being murdered you could be a
christian and
completely reject biblical morality and
the bible's teachings on marriage and
and uh and family and sex and all of
that
that's seductive okay that has attracted
more than just
a segment of political conservatives
that has attracted
millions of people across the board and
it has led to the
uh to the
collapse of the church in america
and she she surveys all of that damage
and sees trump as the problem sees him
as the problem is but now at the end now
he's the problem
just uh i i feel like i probably do her
too much credit to say that
this is oblivious or ignorant on her
part i think she knows better
but she's too afraid she's too afraid to
stand up i mean you can
you can stand up as a christian
apologist as a christian
evangelist you can stand up and talk
about trumpism and
you'll be applauded by most of the
people who you want to applaud you
now you stand up and talk about sexual
morality
talk about defending the family
then that's a different story that takes
actual courage and she doesn't have it
and so that's what we get from her
you know when it comes to buying holiday
gifts um
i i admit uh it's not my specialty
that's why um as i've said before i'm so
happy that i'm married
that's the number one strategy i would
suggest for buying holiday gifts is to
get married
but here's another strategy mack weldon
um thanks to mack weldon
it's super easy and simple to find
something great to buy
for you know especially a guy no matter
which guy you're shopping for whether
it's mac weldon's warm knit tops
undershirts or sunday lounge pants mac
weldon has men's basics that are
guaranteed
to keep everyone on your list
comfortable and also they're going to
they're going to feel great and they're
going to look great
mac weldon has all kinds of stuff
they've got men's essentials socks
shirts
hoodies underwear polos active shorts
mac weldon promises comfort and a
consistent fit and also
you're going to look great at the same
time and there's there's technology
involved in this wide ranges of
customized fabrics that can keep up
with you no matter what your day looks
like no matter what you're doing
um and they've also got the program
weldon blue totally free a loyalty
program
level one gets you free shipping for
life once you reach level two
by spending 200 you get 20 off every
order for the next year
and that's a benefit so if you're using
macwell then you're buying a gift
that's a benefit you get for yourself as
well so give yourself a gift give
someone else a gift at the same time
win the gift-giving season and get 20
off your first order visit
macweldon.com walsh and enter promo code
walsh
that's macweldon.com walls promo code
walsh for 20
off mack weldon reinventing men's basics
and on december 21st remember now this
is coming up very soon the historical
docu-series apollo 11 what we saw
will be available exclusively at
dailywire.com
this was originally released as an audio
podcast for apple and spotify
lots of people listened to it at the
time and uh it was just got a great
reception
for good reason it was a very well done
podcast but now it's going to be
available to watch as well as listen to
on the daily wire
apple tv or roku app or at dailywire.com
this docu-series takes a detailed look
at the apollo 11 mission to land a man
on the
moon it's a dramatically inspiring story
apollo 11 what we saw
fantastic series to watch with your
loved ones this this
holiday season over christmas break if
you're looking for something to do
uh maybe if the weather isn't so great
looking for something to do inside that
i would suggest put this on and right
now
you can get it for 20 off with code
watch when you become an insider or
above member over at dailywire.com
subscribe and make sure to downl
subscribe to get 20 off your membership
with codewatch and access all of our new
and existing content all right let's get
now to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we're canceling zania jones he's a
transgender activist
self-proclaimed science writer who
recently presented the argument for
potentially putting
all children on hormone blockers now
just for a little context and background
here jones runs a youtube account
i'll give you a little taste of that
just you know just so you understand
who this is coming from this is jones
and some other person a couple years ago
reacting to a tucker carlson segment
which itself the segment was reacting to
jones statement
that straight men are transphobic for
not wanting to date trans women
and this is what zania jones had to say
about that listen
i feel like this is just his way of
saying
oh you expected people to just
re-examine
some belief that they hold about a
marginalized group
oh you you just you just all wanna [ __ ]
us that is it
no the entire reason i brought this up
was because there are
so many street guys who are into
us there are a ton of people who would
be into us
but they have hang-ups about it because
they think oh
trans women aren't women which is false
because
trans women are women obviously
if they could get past that then maybe
they'd realize that they could have a
really good time with us
i am trying to help them here
people who like trans women or might
like trans women
but have issues with it because of
everything that society
says uh okay you you yeah there you go i
don't think we need to watch more than
that
uh just just very quickly no there are
no straight
men who are into you or could be
by definition i mean by definition if
you're a straight man
you are attracted to biological females
if you're attracted to anything but
biological females and you're a man
you're not a straight man
by definition so there you go there's
jones um
jones has declared that children now
this is this is this is the new thing
jones has declared that children should
not be forced to undergo
the permanent and irreversible changes
that come with their own puberty
without first quote a professional
evaluation
suggesting that a child's natural
process of growth and maturity
somehow constitutes a human rights
violation jones says that
the argument that children cannot give
appropriate consent for hormone blockers
necessarily leads to the conclusion
that we should be quote putting every
single cis and trans person on puberty
blockers until they are able to offer
quote informed consent
to go through puberty jones presents
puberty as
a choice and one that every child should
have the right to
accept or decline and in order to bring
about this utopia apparently children
should all
be drugged by default now this is quite
insane of course it's
hard to know where to begin in
explaining why it's insane
but one crucial point to make is that
puberty is just
one stage in and facet of
human development if if if puberty
violates consent
then my bones violated my consent by
making me six feet tall
actually six foot one at least that's
what i say certainly my metabolism has
committed
an unspeakable crime against me by
slowing down without asking first and
ensuring that i can no longer eat at
cinnabun without
the evidence showing up around my
midsection in fact even as i
as i say these words my heart is pumping
blood without asking permission my liver
has taken it upon itself to filter blood
regardless of my personal preferences i
must also note with special
disappointment that
uh my body has never sprouted wings so
that i can fly in spite of my repeated
demands
to that end see i exist here in this
body on this planet in this reality as
this person
and almost everything about my body this
planet and this reality exists
exists independent of how i feel about
it
our consent cannot be violated by nature
because nature is outside the realm of
consent
looters who destroy your store have
committed a crime against you
but a hurricane that destroys your store
has not
you just like you are not oppressed or
victimized by
a natural process occurring in or to
your body
even ones you don't like even death
itself
because this is all a part of being a
human person
and to say that you a human person are a
victim of being a human person
is incoherent now on the other hand you
can be a victim of and have your consent
violated by
artificial substances intentionally
introduced into your body in order to
halt your natural growth
if these drugs are given to you as a
child when your brain has not yet
developed to the point where it's able
to properly evaluate all the options and
make a truly informed choice
then you are a victim something is being
done
to you artificially by another conscious
agent
and you did not really choose it because
you are not able to make those sorts of
choices
and this is science we're talking about
the prefrontal cortex the region of your
brain heavily involved in
decision-making discernment
evaluating choices and so on is not
completely online until the age of 25 at
the age of 9 or 10 or 12
it's not even close to fully operational
that's why children cannot be entrusted
to make
any life-altering decisions for
themselves at all
this is also the whole reason why we say
it's rape for adults to have sex with
children
no matter what the children say the
child cannot choose
a sexual relationship with an adult
because they cannot know what it entails
what the consequences will be
what it all means this very same logic
clearly means that pubescent children do
not take drugs
they are given drugs if an adult having
sex with a child is not having sex with
him but raping him
then an adult giving hormone pills to a
child is not medicating him
but poisoning him but the one thing i
will say
for the demented and evil idea presented
by zania jones
i'll say that it's entirely consistent
with every other demented and evil item
on the radical lgbt agenda
in fact it's the logical conclusion of
those things
if sex is assigned at birth by
unspecified nefarious forces
then puberty is part of that unfair
assignment
if we must break free from this
assigning process
by letting children choose their gender
then they should be able to choose
when and if they undergo puberty zinea's
point
is inescapably inescapably correct
if you accept the underlying trans
narrative
many people in our culture do accept it
or pretend to accept it
because they're too scared to be honest
about what they really think and that
means
that compulsory hormone pills for all
children
is not as far-fetched as it sounds we
are
marching on our way to that destination
as we speak but preemptively in the
meantime
uh this person is absolutely
incontrovertibly
canceled and we'll leave it there for
today
thanks for watching have a great day
godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo valdoski
the show is edited by danny d'amico our
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nika geneva and
production assistant mckenna waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton